Transcriber: raghad rae
المدقّق: Manal Abed Al Rahman
(موسيقى بيانو)
(تنتهي الموسيقى)
(تصفيق)
يسعد مسائكم جميعا.
أعرفكم عن نفسي. أنا عزالدين عاشور،
مدير مدرسة راست لتعليم الموسيقى.
أود أن أحكي لكم عن فكرة المشروع
التي بدأت في أواخر 2019،
و بالرغم من بدايتها في ظرف سيء
الذي هو كان ظرف كورونا،
إلا أن الجهد الذي بذلناه
والإصرار على النجاح
الحمد لله أدى لنجاح الفكرة.
الفكرة بدأت عندما كنت أنا أدرس موسيقى
في بيت لحم، وقسم من دراستي
كان في رام الله،
كنت أصادف بعض الطلاب
الذين جاءوا لدراسة الموسيقى من الخليل.
كان سبب مجيئهم لمدن ثانية هو
عدم وجود مدارس أو معاهد لتعليم
موسيقى في محافظة الخليل.
كنت ألمس في تقصير
أي عدم وجود مؤسسات مهتمة
بأنشطة ثقافية بأنشطة فنية.
حاولت من خلال هذه الفكرة
إشراك محافظة الخليل بالنشاط الفني،
وبالأنشطة الثقافية.
بدأنا المشروع في عام 2019
والأن، مر يعني بعدة مراحل.
طبعًا كانت بدايتنا بداية صعبة،
لم يكن هناك تقبل لهذه الفكرة
من المجتمع في البداية
بحكم أن هناك صورة نمطية مطبوعة
عند الناس عن أي نشاط فني،
أو أي شيء له علاقة بالفن أو بالموسيقى.
وأنه دائمًا يتعارض مع الدين،
ومع عاداتنا، ومع تقاليدنا.
كانت الفكرة هي دائمًا راسخة في ذهني،
أنه يجب أن نعكس صورة عكس هذه الصورة،
يعني لا، نريد أن نقدم الموسيقى بما يتناسب
مع عاداتنا، ومع تقاليدنا، ومع ديننا
خصوصًا مدينة الخليل كبلد محافظ،
كان يجب أن نتماشى معها.
تماشينا مع هذه الخصوصية والحمد لله،
كان الشيء مقنع للناس وكان مفرح لهم.
كان هناك تقبل كبير وفرح كبير
من أولياء أمور الطلاب.
وهذا الأمر أدى إلى نجاح فكرتنا.
والأن بالنسبة للتحديات التي واجهناها،
طبعًا يعني هي كانت كثيرة.
كانت هناك تحديات اجتماعية كما قلنا،
لم يكن ثمة قبول لأي نشاط متعلق بالموسيقى
أو بالفن للأسباب التي تكلمنا عنها.
ثمة تحديات سياسية،
أن موضوع الموسيقى دائمًا
في أي حدث سياسي سيئ،
وطبعًا هذه أحداث كثيرة في بلدنا،
دائمًا ما يتأثر موضوع الموسيقى سلبًا
لأنه يُعتبر....ليس وقته،
لدينا الآن شهداء،
لدينا الآن جرحى،
تجد أن هناك دائمًا
تأثيرًا سلبيًا لأحداث كهذه
على موضوع الموسيقى.
كان لدينا تحديات اقتصادية،
نحن كمؤسسة يعني...
هي حديثة، بدأت من جديد.
لسنا مدعومين من أي أحد،
يعني كان هذا بكل تواضع جهدي الشخصي.
كنت أعمل لنقدر على إيصال
الثقافة الموسيقية لأكبر عدد من الناس،
إلا أن قدرات الناس الاقتصادية كانت
تحول دون أن يتمكنوا من  تعليم
أولادهم هذه الثقافة الجديدة.
استقبلنا نحن كمدرسة عددًا من الطلاب
الذين شعرنا بأن لديهم مواهب في هذا المجال
ومن دون أن يتكلفوا
بأي تكاليف عندما كنا نشعر
بأن هذا الطالب عنده موهبة
وبإمكانه أن يقدم شيئًا رائعًا.
كنا نستقبله، ولكن للأسف
إمكانياتنا كانت محدودة.
لجأنا لكثير  من مؤسسات،
يعني محافظة الخليل،
بلدية الخليل، غرفة التجارة في الخليل،
للأسف، لم نجد القبول
من هذه المؤسسات.
استمريت بجهدي الشخصي حتى اليوم،
وبالرغم من هذه الصعوبات كلها،
أنا مستمر وعندي رسالة وأريد تأديتها،
وأمل أن أقدر على الاستمرار في أداء
هذه الرسالة بالرغم من كل هذه الصعوبات.
شكرا لكم ويعطيكم ألف عافية.